Brad Pitt makes his first public  appearance since his split from Angelina  Jolie the 52 year old actor stepped out  Monday night in Los Angeles for a  private screening of moonlight a new  film produced by his company Plan B  Brad's long time pal Julia Roberts  joined him as the two hosted the event  in seemingly good spirits they spoke to  the crowd and posed with moonlight actor  trivanti Rhodes and the writer director  Barry Jenkins this marks the first time  Brad has been photographed out in public  since Angelina filed for divorce in  September on Monday a rep for the  actress confirmed to ET a legal  agreement was signed by the former  couple regarding a temporary custody  arrangement for their six children the  rep explained quote the six children  will stay in their mother's custody and  the children will continue therapeutic  visits with their father